today we're going to be talking about a
problem in logic and how in solving that
problem Alan Turing almost inadvertently
invented the modern digital computer so
we start back at the beginning of the
20th century where mathematicians had
posed this problem in logic we're
interested in finding do these premises
entail this conclusion so premises are
the bits you start off with in an
argument there are your the bits you
know at the beginning or your
assumptions and the conclusion is the
bit you want to establish the bit that
you reason to with your argument and we
want to know is there a test that will
tell us yes for sure these premises do
or don't Intel this conclusion is there
an automatic way of finding out whether
they do or whether they don't so that's
the problem it's called the decision
problem a mathematicians wanted to find
out is there an answer to the decision
problem for first-order logic that's the
kind of logic you learn in philosophy or
mathematics in university so lots of
mathematicians were trying to work out
is first-order logic
decidable that is can we automatically
test whether the premises entail the
conclusion Alan Turing was one of the
first to discover that first-order logic
isn't decidable to prove this it's
really difficult conceptually because
you have to be able to show no possible
program can give you the answer but how
do you do that how do you show something
about every possible program you can't
run through every program one by one but
shirring came up with a brilliant
solution his idea goes something like
this suppose we have a program and let's
just draw it as a black box it's going
to take some inputs and it's going to
give us some outputs our program is
going to solve some problem a problem
like do the premises entail the
conclusion we ask it a question and it
will give us an answer yes or no now
here's another question
we can ask let's look at all of those
possible programs and we're just
thinking of them as black boxes at the
moment we might want to know is this
program given a certain input going to
give us an answer or is it going to
trundle on forever
and never give us an answer that is is
it going to halt or is it not going to
halt eventually so think about your
computer running you want it to give you
an answer or whether it's a good answer
or a bad answer it's better than no
answer no answer would mean the computer
trundles around forever and ever in a
loop and you would just never know
whether it's going to finish today
tomorrow or never so halting is good so
there's another question we can ask
given some program and some inputs will
it ever halt now it turns out that our
logical problem to these premises Intel
this conclusion is very similar to this
halting problem in fact if we can solve
the logical problem then we can solve
the halting problem will this program
halt on this input so the clever part of
cheering's proof is to show that it's
impossible for any machine however
clever it is to solve the halting
problem that is to tell us whether a
given machine with a given input will
halt or not and here's how we did it
let's suppose we've got a machine or a
program that solves the problem for us
it solves the halting problem don't
worry about how it works let's just
think of it as a black box
taking the description of a machine and
an input and giving us an answer
yes it will halts or no it won't hold
just suppose that's possible call that
machine H for the halting problem if you
give me that machine I can transform it
into a different machine like this I
stick some extra bits on it so that if
it gives me a yes answer I make it loop
forever without ever stopping if it
gives me a no answer on the other hand
it's going to halt straight away let's
call that big
machine the whole thing H+ now here's
another question we can ask what happens
if I feed the whole machine into itself
so I'm going to put H+ in here and H+ in
here so the question I'm now asking is
I'm feeding H+ into itself so I'm asking
the question does H+ Holt give an input
H+ and here's where it all goes wrong
because if H+ does Holt we get a yes
answer but then it loops forever
so it doesn't halt on the other hand if
it doesn't halt we get a no answer but
then it holds so if it does hold then it
doesn't hold but if it doesn't hold then
it does halt either way we get a
contradiction it's a paradox but what
that shows is we started off assuming
that we can solve the problem we've
ended up with a paradox so our
assumption was bad it turns out there's
no possible machine no possible program
that solves the halting problem the
really clever bit about cheering's idea
is it doesn't matter what kind of
program or machine is it doesn't matter
whether it's an abstract algorithm
whether it's a real computer a physical
computer it doesn't matter what it is
we've proved that no such program is
possible churring as part of his
argument had to say a little bit about
what's going on in these black boxes and
the idea is that every card represents
win structuring holy